Hot take,
depopulation.
Is humanity going to make it, Dalton?
And will it be too few people or too
many? Yeah, I mean, the graphs look bad.
They look really bad.
This is Dalton plus Michael, and this
feels to be a little different. We're
going to do a little bit of 2025 in
review. What are hot takes
from 2025?
>> of takes, Michael.
>> of takes. Dalton was inspired by the
Colin Jost Michael Che
end of the year SNL skit where they give
each other extremely challenging jokes
to say aloud that will get themselves
canceled. Let's not do that. We're not
going to do that. No, but it's a cool
idea. Maybe next year. Anyways, where do
you want to start? Where where what's
the first first hot take topic? So,
let's start with
San Francisco, Michael. Let's start at
the the hottest of hot takes. So, what's
your hot take on the status of the city
and politics and like the whole shebang?
My hot take is like, if you're reading
it on Twitter,
it's like it's there's a greater than
50% chance it's wrong. In what way?
>> Just just wrong. Just like just assume
anything that is meaning about San
Francisco, either positive or negative,
on Twitter is wrong.
>> So, is it better? You're just saying
it's different.
>> It's just different. It's just like it's
just like there's no signal. Like the
signal that you're getting on the things
that are meaning is like
you should ignore that signal. It's the
fuzz. It's not real signal. I'm sure
they're all going to listen to you. You
solved it, Michael. Thank you.
>> Solved the problem.
Nothing's going to trend be San
Francisco. I think my second hot take,
people give politicians way too much
agency. I don't care who the people
leading San Francisco were, if you have
COVID, if you have the emptying of
downtown's office spaces, and if you
have a defund the police movement,
you're going to be in a challenging
situation.
I don't care who's leading a city, if
you're emerging from those things, Yep.
[laughter] you're going to be in a
better situation. And all too often I
feel like humans need like viral
narratives to explain simple things. And
like yes, there are, you know, there's
more work to be done and blah blah blah,
all these things, but like
those two trends are generally going to
hold. And probably the people running
the city are just trying to do best with
the general
>> [laughter]
>> situation that they're in. What's that
phrase or like the king goes down to the
thing and tells us
I'm going to show all of my citizens how
powerful I am, and I'm going to I'm
going to command the tide to go out.
>> [laughter]
>> And the tide doesn't move, and he's like
that's
that's my power. That's what I I don't
know that one. Those are my moves. So
anyways, I think that's my hot take on
San Francisco. Yeah. The Twitter
narrative is basically completely
incorrect. All right, what do you got
for me? Hot take,
depopulation.
Is humanity going to make it, Dalton?
And will it be too few people or too
many? Yeah, I mean, the graphs look bad.
They look really bad.
I remember
a long time ago when I was like an
undergrad at Stanford, I remember seeing
a building on the campus. Yes. And there
was a dumpster next to it. Yes.
>> And it was full of books that had
clearly been thrown out of the building.
>> Interesting.
>> And of course this evoked my natural
curiosity. It steered me away. It's
trying but why would you throw a bunch
of books and journals into a dumpster?
>> Yeah. And it was all from something
called, I think, the Stanford Food
Research Institute.
>> Okay. And I looked into it a little bit
at the time, and basically it was a
whole department  think tank Mhm.
that as far as I could tell, again, I
could maybe get some of the subtlety
wrong.
>> Sure.
>> But it was basically encouraging people
to stop having children because there
wasn't enough food to feed people in the
world. Yeah.
>> So, there may be more to it than that,
but
>> Yeah.
>> Stanford shut that down, which is why
all the journals that were studying the
like
theory of this ended up getting shut
down. Obviously this theory became very
popular in certain countries.
I might argue it became part of public
policy globally.
>> Interesting.
>> And so, I think if you read a lot of
books in what, like the '60s and '70s,
>> Yeah. this was like
if you were really into like
environmentalism and trying to save the
world, trying to slow the rate of
population was like the coolest thing
you could be.
>> Yeah. Wow, is that different now? And by
the way, I think the evidence that this
wasn't the problem was a bit hiding in
plain sight. Well, it's almost like it
was so effective of raising living
standards in places
that that it all kind of solved itself.
Like basically the Yes. a bunch the
abundance of
raising standard of living caught fixed
all the stuff. It was almost as if we
have an equilibrium, and we thought we
had to manage the like it's a very human
perspective like obviously we have to
manage our population equilibrium. We've
never done that ever until this point.
We've been around for a while, but
obviously now we're smart. It looks bad.
It looks bad for Japan. I mean, I don't
know. Look, I I'm not It looks not my
line of work. It looks bad for America.
Like I love how it's like
I I see these graphs where it's like
China population depopulation is going
to like kill everything, right?
>> Yeah. And then like America, fine. And
then it's like America fine includes
immigration.
And you're like, well, great. Like
that's not repopulating the world.
That's just Yeah. [laughter] us opening
our doors, which I love immigration, but
like
it's not solving the larger problem. I
want to give PJ a little bit of credit
here. I think that
you know, going to Yale and kind of
seeing
people talking about ideas who didn't
always seem that smart, I think I kind
of just dismissed the power of ideas a
little bit. I think I dismissed academia
a little too much. And I remember kind
of, you know, PJ talking
about something sort of like, hey, this
stuff happened. Like I I just feel like
we just ignore college campuses. Just
ignore that. That's like it, whatever,
who cares.
And like it's like there's some ideas
that when they take hold, they can have
a lot of power. And I think this is one
of them. You would assume at some point
someone would do the math and be like,
no no, folks. Like I think there's still
people who aren't having kids today cuz
they believe that we are like
going to overpopulate. It's bad for the
environment.
>> Environmentalism.
>> Yeah, and it's like
Wow, that's a powerful idea. And what's
crazy is like the solutions are all kind
of random from governments. So, like,
well, we'll give people a tax credit.
The solutions are not good.
>> The solutions are [laughter]
basically tax credits, and I I think I
read that in all the attempts thus far
to do those, it's like 0% effective. I
read that basically when you do it, you
basically push up the people who were
going to have kids into getting the
incentive, and then you have this like
fall off
because like, well, I had my kids early.
Like I don't I'm shocked the government
isn't great at figuring out incentives
for humans to do things. And then it's
like, wow, shock. Especially things that
involve watching something for 18 years.
That's like a big one. All right, so
that's one.
Next one,
AGI, Dalton. January 1, 2025, did you
think we were going to be closer or
further from AGI than you believe today?
I think it depends on how you define it.
I think the models improved faster than
I would have expected January 1, 2025.
>> Yes. Just in the past two or three
weeks, Yeah. there have been a bunch of
new models that dropped. Literally in
the past two weeks, Google's coming on
strong.
>> everyone put out new models, and they
all seem pretty good. And the other
funny thing about the new models is it
takes a while to know how good they are.
>> Yep. You can't just run the benchmark
and automatically know if they're good.
>> No. And so, I think the rate of
improvement is higher than I expected,
but I'm not sure, depending on how you
define AGI,
this is way better than I would have
expected at the beginning of the year. I
still think the timelines are similar to
where we started the year. I'll answer
the same way, but I think because I was
skeptical of AGI in January, and I'm
skeptical now. Okay.
>> Yeah, I think that like AGI is such a
cool and almost viral idea, and such an
impactful idea, that it can
it can suck up all the oxygen in the
room. Yeah. I remember talking to a
founder
August, and she was like, oh, you know,
I talked to
all the people working on this stuff,
and they're like, yeah, we're you know,
we're like six to no more than 18 months
away from just superintelligence. And
you know, they were sitting there just
imagining what the world would be like,
as if they're making plans.
>> Yeah, like near-term plans, right? It's
weird. I feel like that did not help
this founder at all. One,
I think that those people while making
their plans were not operating their
businesses as if AGI was six months
away. Still, it was like this weird kind
of duality that's hard to capture. But
two, I think that like I'm always
skeptical of ideas that take all the
oxygen out of the room. I think this is
related to our next hot take topic,
which is self-driving. And so, let's
start by by what I think the parallels
are.
>> Yes.
>> Is man, in 2015, Yes. it felt like we
were at the precipice of self-driving
working.
>> Yeah.
>> And I spent a lot of time
being like, man, my kids never going to
need to learn how to drive.
>> [laughter]
>> And And remember we had a colleague who
didn't know how to drive. And he
pre-ordered a Tesla full self-driving in
like 2016.
>> Yeah. Cuz he was like, oh, well, this is
going to self-drive in like 2017.
>> Yes.
>> And so, I think we were living in an
environment
where it really did seem like ubiquitous
self-driving would happen in 2017, 2018.
>> Yep. Your former co-founder Kyle was a
founder of Cruise. And And so, I just I
think we were like really drinking the
Kool-Aid.
>> Yes. I think with hindsight, we were
totally right. Yes. And I think in
hindsight it took longer than we
thought. Yes.
Like the thing that we thought was going
to happen in 2017 is now happening in
2025. The tricky thing was like I would
say it's like it's it's not it's
happening. It's started to happen. It's
happening in the Bay Area. Yeah. Not
across the US. Yeah, I took Yes. I'm in
the Tesla Robo-Taxi beta.
>> Yeah. I took one here. Yeah. And I take
Waymo constantly. Yes. I would still
give that a maybe. What is the ratio of
teleoperators
to cars on the road at Waymo? Yeah.
I still think this would have been
within the range of what we would have
satisfied us in 2017. I'm not saying I
know the number. It You don't think it
is? I I think it is. I think that in
to 17, I No, no, I think I thought
self-driving was going to be a solved
problem. There are no humans in the loop
when I'm doing a Google search. Yeah.
And then to your point, and then of
course, have we rolled it out to yet any
of like the Yeah, right. So to me And
actually there was a technical
bottleneck. Again, this is the other
fellow. Yeah. My My understanding of
people that work on this, when I've
spoken with them,
is that they ended up deleting a lot of
like hard-coded C++ rules. And it's just
all ML stuff that wasn't even invented.
Yeah. Computer science had to catch up
is my understanding. Again, maybe
someone in the comments will disagree,
but that is my understanding from people
that work on this stuff. I think that's
what kind of frustrates me about these
topics is that like
if we're directionally correct, but the
time frame's off, it really impacts how
you should like operate your life.
There's a meaningful difference between
an AI model that can do a lot of work
for you that like makes you a
superpower. I mean, whatever street like
let's say an AI model or a foundation
model company that can make every person
feel like they get the value that cursor
gives an engineer. There's
so much distance between that and
superintelligence. Yeah. I wouldn't be
surprised if we had a whole new job of
teleoperators, and there wouldn't be
hundreds of thousands of teleoperators
that are helping manage a self-driving
fleets as they expand across the
country. And we would call that
self-driving. And it it would work for
as a user, it would feel like it, right?
I'm not driving. To me, there's a
parallel there, right? Like versus like
AGI superintelligence, I think we have
to define a kind of cross the line, and
I think like we could be way further
away. I think that's fair. But again, I
think the parallel is
the crazy utopians, I think we're right
about self-driving. I would basically
make the bet that the
wacky AGI people are right Mhm. just on
a longer timeline. Do you know Do you
know what I'm trying to say? Like Well,
I think I think they'll probably be
right about every every wacky thing
we're hearing, I think is going to end
up being true. That's my bet. I think
long enough timeline, I would completely
agree with you. Yeah. I just think that
when I start seeing people making
strategies about their startups or
making strategies about their life Yes.
>> assuming we're on an 18-month timeline.
>> Yep. Delaying having kids, say.
>> Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm like
>> [laughter]
>> The timeline caveat's a large caveat, I
would say.
>> Yeah. I would say. All right, what's the
next one? Space.
It's been an interesting year for space.
We have seen Starlink basically go
mainstream. Yep.
We've seen a lot more space startups
being funded. Yep. We've seen space
defense kind of take a little bit.
What's your sense?
>> Yes, I
I think I put out a YC video request for
startups about this. But basically, as a
side effect of SpaceX
working, Yes. the cost per pound to get
something into space Yes. is dropping
rapidly. It's like Moore's law, where
remember the number of transistors in a
chip was doing this. The cost to send
something into space is doing this. Yes.
So it's getting exponentially cheaper.
Yes. So now you can do all sorts of
wacky stuff, cuz you can get Yes. things
in space. Sounds like the SpaceX IPO is
real. Yeah. So I think this is a really
exciting time. My space hot take
is very similar, which is like we
haven't experienced cheap launch yet.
Yeah. People who've been in the space
industry for a while are like, "Oh my
god, we finally have cheap launch."
And I think we're going to look at back
at this time and be like, "God, that was
expensive launch." Yeah. [laughter]
If you told me we've reached the iPhone
moment where it makes sense to start
building iPhone apps, I would believe
you. If you told me that we haven't yet,
I think I still might believe like Yeah.
I still might believe Starship is the
iPhone moment. I'll give you another one
that's interesting though. Free space.
What do you think about space companies
having to compete with SpaceX for launch
space? Right? It's tricky.
I've been multiple companies now that
have gotten bumped off their launches.
And I'm like, "Oh, can you like
negotiate like who was it?" And they're
like, "It was It was SpaceX."
It was Starlink. Wow. And I was like,
"Yeah, I guess you can't really
negotiate, can you?" So what you're
saying is we should buy SpaceX stock at
IPO. No, no. There's no
No. No. Another big topic from the COVID
days.
What's your hot take on in-person versus
remote? Obviously, in-person is better,
and it's depressing how much of big
company stuff
is putting the toothpaste back in the
tube when they went remote. I do think
there's stuff that stuck
from that era that was probably good,
where people are way more willing to do
Zoom meetings now. I think the norm has
changed in some ways in a positive,
where Imagine how weird it would have
been to try to do
nothing over a Zoom. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That wouldn't Like I'm glad I can just
like hop on Zoom to send to you certain
types of meetings.
>> I agree. Like how That's way better.
>> Yep. Real-time communication, chat got
way more popularized. Yeah. I am torn
about this in-person versus remote.
I think this is what I'd come to
believe. I think large companies are
always remote. You know, you get over
some number of employees, and the
chances that the three people you work
with most closely are
have their desks next to you basically
goes to zero.
>> Yeah. So I never really thought this was
a fair debate, cuz I think the debate
was really for startups. It always
seemed obvious that like you should be
in-person. Yep. And so I felt like this
was a fight that we had to fight for a
while, which was just kind of silly. And
now it's like,
"Okay, can we go back to the normal?"
Have we not run this experiment
involuntarily? Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, but to me, I think that was the
shocking thing was that like a bunch of
startups that did not want to run like
big companies were copying the best
practices of big companies.
>> Yep. What do we have left? Are we in a
bubble, Michael? I think that like as
long as there's another bubble that
keeps whatever bubbles going inflated.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. There's always going
to be a new bubble. Yeah. I'm going to
say no. And I'm usually the skeptic. I
don't think we know the amount of impact
that even today's
AI tools can have in business.
>> Yeah. I think we are so early in the
adoption cycle that even if all AI
development stopped today, like we would
still get like tons of improvement. Cuz
like adoption is Yeah. very, very small.
I think my nuanced take is the
following. As a founder, I learned
that debt is bad, because debt like
causes startups to blow up.
>> Yeah, ask PG about this, right? This is
one of his like evergreen topics, which
is never
put debt on your startup. It feels like
free money, it feels like cheap money.
There's all these covenants in the
contract that comes when you take debt.
So that when debt goes bad, it goes
really bad, and you lose your company.
>> Super fast.
>> Okay? So debt in startups is like a bad
mix. And then if you look at prior
bad economic cycles, Yes. debt is in
there somewhere. Like I think if you go
all the way back to like the 1929 stock
market crash, people were like taking
out loans to buy equity. So taking out
debt to buy equity, I think we can say
is probably a bad idea if you don't know
what you're doing. The great financial
crisis was very similar. Right? It was
It was debt-driven.
>> Yes. And so my nuance here is of all the
things that I see that kind of concern
me, it would be debt issuance
to finance data center spend, to finance
buying graphics cards. And that is
downwind of all the stuff we do. Again,
we're not in that business, man. Yeah.
>> But if you look at the whole machine,
there's a lot of debt that's being
issued right now. If we were to reframe
it like, was the internet a bubble? No.
Was there a bubble in the deployment of
fiber optic cable? Yes. And did
[laughter] the people in the business of
laying the fiber optic cable lose their
ass? Yes. Yes, they definitely did, and
we as consumers benefited
>> Yes. from the fiber optic cables getting
laid. You know, our startups benefited
from these things. We're all downwind of
it. But the actual people that were in
the business of financing that fiber
optic cable, that was That was bad. I am
quite positive that somebody is
overbuilding or inefficiently building
at some level of the AI stack. Like it
seems like it's almost impossible Yeah.
that wouldn't be the case. And so that
does worry me, but that doesn't mean
that this stuff doesn't work and isn't
solving problems for customers and all
that on the like
user-facing stuff. But I do wonder how
much debt is actually in this thing.
That worries me, man.
>> from the perspective of a participant in
the stock market, those kinds of things
can have short-term negative impacts on
the stock market. But in terms of the
Well, and I do wonder,
let's say all the AI stuff works, which
again, I I think it will. Yeah. The
value of a lot of the legacy software
companies that are going to get killed
goes down. There's going to be some
churn, man. You're It's so funny. You
>> [laughter]
>> This is You're defining bubble in a like
how someone might experience the world
way. I think I'm defining I'm defining
it in a very narrowly Yeah, yeah.
Like yeah.
Could there be a lot of AI-caused
turmoil in public markets? Probably
there will be.
>> [laughter]
>> Are you sure? If you define bubbles like
that, Yeah, who might a
Use the actual definition, Michael. Ugh.
But if you define this as like, is this
a hoax? No. You know, when we were
giving out like mortgages to people who
couldn't afford mortgages because we
could resell them before anyone would
figure that out. That's like a hoax.
Like that's there there's no value
creation happening. Yeah. I think in
this situation we definitely have value
creation, but like Public market turmoil
could be caused for all kinds of
reasons, right? It's fair. So, in any
way, that's the thing like of all the
things I've seen in the past in the
2025, what has worried me Sure. some of
this data center stuff seems a little
scary, man. Uh the market turmoil. All
right, and the last one, this is
probably secretly my favorite. Uh
abundance versus affordability. Let me
Let me set this up.
The Democratic Party is searching for a
message. The Trump era theoretically
is coming to a close or a change, and it
seems like there's two competing
messages. There is more of a moderate
abundance,
can we make government work better?
And there is more of a progressive
affordability. What are the things
that happen in the economy or amongst
business or even in the government that
makes it harder for you to pay for
everyday things. How do you think about
this dichotomy here? Technology has
consistently delivered us
um abundance. Sure. And if you just
think about all the cool stuff we get,
like smartphones and Sure. good health
care and cheap clothes, like all this
good stuff. We live in an age of
abundance and it's only um increasing.
It's funny you say that cuz like I think
somebody that was like examining the
fossil record would obvi- I think would
agree with you.
>> Yeah, if you're like like what kind of
What was the life in the 1930s like?
>> Yeah, yeah. Well, I don't think they had
a lot of this stuff, man. I don't I
don't
I objectively I could
Well, like what's weird is that like
isn't it interesting the idea of like
what percentage of the population of
America would say I feel like I'm living
in a time of abundance? I think
stuff used to be cheaper.
And again, this is this isn't my area of
expertise, but the housing stuff It's a
real a really an affordability type
There is not an abundance of cheap
housing.
>> Nope. And I think it's easy to look at
the past with with rose-colored glasses
and gloss Remember when gas used to cost
whatever per gallon and when a house
cost a hundred thousand dollars Yeah.
and
not
admit that there's a trade-off that you
had to live
without the internet or you know, like
there's all these other trade-offs. Yes.
Yes. I think it's easy to like forget
that there was a trade that we all
implicitly taken. Maybe some people
would say, "I don't want to make that
trade. I'd love to go live in Well, like
I could be 6 again, right? Well, since
you go back to the 50s, a big trade is
like the number of employed women in the
market in the workforce. Well, that's a
trade. There's like big trades. Like,
yeah, like I think what scares me about
this question is that like
and this is what kind of both both
scares me but comforts me about politics
and government.
Affordability is clearly the short-term
campaign message that is like a better
campaign. Like if you asked me, "Hey
Michael, you can run." And they'll be
like, "Your banner can either say
abundance or affordability." I'm like,
"Got it, affordability."
Abundance is clearly the good
governance. Like if we actually want our
government to deliver goods and
services, we should be doing abundance
work. I think the problem that I have,
but then also with the hopeful side, is
like I just don't think we do long-term
planning well. I think abundance is like
a hey, you know, if you eat your
vegetables when you're 70, you'll live
another 10 years.
>> [laughter]
>> And I think affordability is like, "Hey,
do you want to go to the movies and like
do something like this weekend?"
And I think that as humans and therefore
as societies both of humans, we don't do
long-term well.
However,
we made it. Something about this like
what seems like awkwardly short-term
optimizations
>> seems to somehow keep working. Yeah. And
so it's like
I can sit back and judge academically
and was like, "Well, you're not You're
not eating your peas and carrots, like
da da da da da." But like maybe we
should take a second and not on a
system that is kind of working, right?
Like I think it's been my experience
just even locally in San Francisco. Like
at first you're like, "You do it this
way? Like how could that work?" And then
you're like, "Well,
it is kind of working." Like I was
looking at like Department of Public
Works, like they pick up tons of trash
every day.
>> [laughter]
>> If you were to say, "Michael, would you
design it like that?" I'd be like,
"Maybe I would. Maybe I won't." But like
it's kind of working. Yeah. Let's not
just on it cuz like
No, I mean that's not the way I would
have done it. So, I don't know. For this
abundance versus affordability, I'm kind
of like, "Oh, man."
My heart is in abundance,
but like I think my brain is in
affordability. And that's what kind of
scares me a little. My brain is in the
campaign message over the governance.
That's like that's a little scary for
me. Yeah, but maybe that's just kind of
like a deep-seated like lack of faith
that we will do good government quickly.
We're talking about 2025, what does that
mean for 2026? What does that look like
in practice? That means I believe the
Democratic Party will have a populist
message that like
bad people make things too expensive.
Wow. Just like I think the Republican
Party has had a bit of a populist
message that immigrants make the country
worse.
And it's a little scary that we're going
to have kind of two
populist messages kind of fighting each
other that I think are like kind of
hiding the real facts.
But uh you know, it's not the first time
you've had populist message.
>> [laughter]
>> You know, it's like it's like
Yeah, we've gotten through this stuff
before. Yeah. When people are like, "Oh
my god, social media is making things
horrible. Like America There's never
been a worse time in America."
Like oh like
is that
I don't want to be that guy, but
[laughter]
You know, it's like I know these are
problems, but like we we've dealt with
worse problems. Like that one's hard.
It's it's uh
especially for a process-oriented person
like
>> Yeah, you're on the front lines. I don't
I don't I'm glad [laughter]
this is not my Yeah, I don't have to go
fix this one. Well, I guess that was
2025. We'll see what happens when AGI
takes us over. This will be produced by
AGI in 2026.
>> [laughter]
>> They have enough footage of us. They
could definitely replicate it. They do.
They do. And I've been saying thank you
every time I use a foundation model, so
we'll be safe.
>> [laughter]
>> Great chat, Dalton.
>> thanks, man.